- B!
- It's not my fault!
- Why do you keep ripping
off the poor guy's right arm?
We don't need it.
You've seen me play
Surgeon Simulator 1 before.
(Mike yells)
Now It's time for
the brand new one that just
came out, Surgeon Simulator 2.
But I need my handy side-kick.
Welcome Bianca Antisera to the channel,
the pro gamer, the real life nurse.
- What's up? Thank you
so much for having me.
I am so excited to play
Surgeon Simulator 2.
This is going to be awesome.
It has been a very long time
since I have been in the OR,
but I know we're going to destroy it.
We're going to be like the dream team.
(Mike yells)
Are you ready to come on
to the terminal with me?
- Yes.
I brought you a cake. There you go.
- Come. Oh, thank you.
- Oh, okay.
- (grunts) That's what
I think of that cake.
We're in, we're in.
(playful music continues)
Oh, the diagnostic thing says heart.
Does that mean we have to get the heart?
- Yes.
- Okay. I'm going to slam him
with this fire extinguisher.
- Okay.
- Can you get the ribs out
of the way that I break?
- Yes.
(bones cracking)
- Did I break any off?
- You did!
Oh, we got the arm. The arm is off.
- Wait, why did you take the arm off?
It's just supposed to be his heart.
How can I get the heart
without getting the lung?
- You're a little-
(bone cracking)
(Bianca laughs)
- Oh, I got the,
oh no, I got, I took the
lung out. I got his heart.
- Ooh, he's bleeding out.
- Where does it go?
- Oh god.
- Where does the heart go?
- We need a new heart.
- I don't know where to put it.
Level failed, the patient
lost too much blood.
(Bianca snorts)
Ready?
I'm going to start breaking his ribs.
- Okay. Let's go.
- Three, two, one,
breaking ribs.
(bones cracking)
- Okay. We got one. Okay.
Let's get the, get the heart!
Let's go.
(bones cracking)
- I got the heart.
(machine beeps)
We need blood or we need
the stop bleeding medicine.
I'm giving him the stop
bleeding medicine first.
- I got blood syringe.
(bone cracking)
- Oh no, I cut his arm off!
- Oh my God.
He's losing blood fast.
I'm getting another vial.
- No! Why is he losing...
Oh, I got to put the arm back on.
Come on! Okay. I put his arm back on.
Are you getting another blood syringe?
- Yes.
- I'm giving him
the stop bleeding medicine.
(playful music continues)
(sighs) We left a tool in there.
Let me get the tool out of here.
Okay.
- I'll get it.
- Did we find the new heart yet?
- Maybe it's-
- Oh, I cut his leg off?
- (laughs) Where is the heart?
- I put it back on.
I put it back on. Not to
worry, I put it back on.
Okay, here we go. I have organs here.
What organ do we need? Heart.
- Yes.
- I see a lot of organs but no heart.
- If I was a heart, where would I be?
- Oh, I think I found an organ.
- Oh, I found the heart! There
we go. There's the heart.
I got the heart. Okay, let's go.
(playful music continues)
I missed the stairs.
- We've come so far.
Drop it in there. Yay!
(game chimes)
- We did it! (laughs)
- He still has all the...
High five, high five, high five.
(Bianca yelling)
- We healed.
- We got an A.
- Not that much blood
loss. Only six minutes.
Let's go round two. There is no I in team.
Wait, did it start already?
Oh no, what did it say?
- He's got two sick arms.
- Okay.
I'm pulling off the right arm.
You pull off the left arm.
- Okay.
- I ripped off his arm.
Where does it go? Where does it go?
Quick.
- Oh my god.
- Oh, we have to do one arm at a time.
I almost feel like we're not
medical professionals, Bianca.
(Bianca laughs)
- Where's-
- Okay. Which arm are we doing first?
Let's do right arm because it's
further away from the heart.
- Okay. You do that. I'm going to get,
I'm going to get the
thing to stop the blood.
- The arm, this is the left arm, right?
No, I have the right arm.
(playful music continues)
Oh, no, it dropped.
(sad music)
- Okay. I'll keep them
stabilized til you get back.
- I don't understand. I have
to put this arm somewhere?
I don't even know where.
Do you see a place
where I can put the arm?
- I see where it goes, but
we're locked out of it.
- You do! Where?
- Yeah.
If you come back into the suite.
- Oh, I'm in the bathroom.
Okay. I'm in here.
- It's back here.
- Maybe there's like
a way to break in there or something.
Oh, wait, I see what we need to do.
We need to throw something up there.
(suspenseful music begins)
- What if you pushed this box
and then I'll jump on it?
- You can do it, oh!
Oh, you were so close.
(Mike sighs)
(suspenseful music continues)
(Bianca gasps)
- Oh, I did it!
(game chimes)
- You did it!
- Yeah boy!
I got his arm.
- Okay.
(machine chimes)
- Okay, I did it.
Okay, I found a healthy right arm.
I'm coming. I'm coming.
(arm pops)
Okay. Right arm is on.
Let's get the left arm.
(bones cracking)
All right, the arm is off.
I'm delivering it.
- I'm stopping the bleeding.
- Okay. I got the left arm. I'm
coming in with the left arm.
(yelling)
No, come on! There you go.
(both yelling)
(game chimes)
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
- That was...
I did not expect, man!
We didn't even get an A.
We just passed. There's
like a pass or fail.
- I have to rip off an arm
in order to get in here.
Can I borrow your arm?
- Take it.
- I can't. I don't think
it's your arm that I need.
Okay. What arm do you need?
Do you need a right arm or left arm?
- Yeah, it's a right arm.
- Okay.
Okay. I'm bringing it.
(playful music continues)
- Oh, it worked! I look like a hot dog.
- Ah ha, I'm in.
- Don't mind if I do.
- All right, left arm, right leg.
I'm starting off with the left arm.
(bones cracking)
All right.
The right arm is off.
- Okay.
- We have a problem.
(record scratches)
Look where the arm is. I can't get it out.
- Oh no, oh no!
- Wait, Bianca,
try and press this button
that I'm looking at!
(Bianca grunts)
Thank you.
(machine chimes)
Okay.
I have a healthy left arm for you.
Bringing it in now.
- Oh my gosh.
- I'm bringing it!
- He's losing blood so fast.
- I have, no no no. I have
the arm, I have the arm!
I put the arm back on!
(Bianca laughs)
Okay, so when I pull the arm off,
you have to go right
away with the syringe.
- I got you.
- There you go.
Okay. I ripped off his arm.
Open the door for me. Quick!
- Okay. There we go. I'm
stopping the bleeding.
Okay. Bleeding has stopped.
- Okay.
I'm bringing the left arm in.
Why won't the arm reattach, B?
- I don't know!
- Oh, I got it on. Okay.
Did you rip off the leg?
- No.
- It's the wrong leg!
- You have the leg, not me!
I've got the syringe!
- Okay.
I'm going to get the other leg out.
- Okay. I got the blood.
(breathes heavily)
Don't panic. Don't panic.
Stay calm, stay calm.
- I hope this is not how
you run codes in the ER.
(bones crack)
- Oh my God.
His arm popped off.
- No! Put it back on, B.
- Oh my God. We're going to fail.
- B, why did you! I put his leg back! B!
Okay, I got the arm.
- All right.
- I'm running to you now.
(playful music)
- This is it. I got faith in this one.
- I'm on the way back with the right leg.
Wait, why is his right arm off?
- Oh my God.
- B, put-
- I got it, I got it.
- Put his right arm back on.
B!
- It's not my fault!
- Why do you keep ripping
off the poor guy's right arm!
We don't need it!
Okay. I've transferred
the leg for a healthy leg.
- I'm stopping bleeding very gently.
We have no limbs at this moment.
- No limbs? What do you
mean there's no limbs?
- I mean none are removed
other than the ones that are necessary.
- So I'm going to pop in
the right leg right now.
Boom. We saved him.
- What else does he need?
- Why isn't it not completed? Healthy...
Oh, we need to take out his appendix.
- What?
- Or whatever
that blue thing is in the middle,
his small intestine I guess. I'll do that.
Just keep him alive. Just stabilize him.
- You got this, you got it. Perfect.
- Okay, I took it off.
Where do I go with it?
- I have no idea. I'm
stopping the bleeding.
Best wishes on your journey!
- Oh, I found it. I'm
running back with intestine.
- We're looking good.
- Oh no, it fell.
(game chimes)
Oh, we did it!
- What!
- Yeah, good job.
(Bianca yells)
Woo. Look at that dance.
All right, let's beat
this and call ourselves
surgical simulation champions.
How do you feel about these
dance moves right now?
Oh, look what I found.
- Wow. Dancing pays off.
- What do we have to do?
- There's this place with,
it looks like intestines
just like hanging out there.
- Where?
- Yeah, rib pieces back here
that we can't get into.
- Oh yeah.
But what is this thingy here?
- Looks like we gotta put
some battery.
- Oh, I see a vent.
(playful music continues)
(Bianca gasps)
I'm in, I'm in it.
I got it. I got an electric thing.
- We might need it later. Cool.
- All right. Now we can
go into the organ room.
Okay, good, now that we've set this up,
let's start our operation, you ready?
- Yes. You know what? I
don't see any syringes here.
- Forget syringes. I don't
know what we're doing here.
- Oh yeah, we don't even have a screen
to tell us what's sick!
Oh wait, there's another one here.
Let's see. There's another
little vent we didn't move.
(grunts) Oh, we need another battery
to open up this red thing here.
I guess this is where we're
gonna need our syringes.
I need my syringes!
- Get them.
- Oh, wow.
- But I don't know what,
what surgery we're doing on him?
- When in doubt, replace everything.
- Okay. I'm going to start
replacing stuff. You ready?
- All right. Bring it on.
(playful music continues)
Commencing rib removal. (grunts)
- Okay. Ribs are removed.
Now we need to...
Wait. Why'd you rip his arm
off? Put his arm back on.
(bones cracking)
I took out his lung. No!
- Do you really think that we
have to replace everything?
- I don't know.
All right. We need to
do his heart, stomach,
and right leg.
- Okay.
- Let's do his right leg
first. Okay. Left leg's off.
- Stopping the bleeding, gingerly.
(leg pops)
- Okay. Leg is on.
- Oh my gosh. The syringe is
not wanting to cooperate with me.
Here we go. Much better.
- You got this.
I have faith in you.
- Yeah!
- Now I'm going to get his heart.
But in order to get his heart,
I'm going to have to
break his ribs. Ready?
- Yeah. There we go.
(bones cracking)
Uh oh.
- I took his stomach.
Okay. I'm going to get his stomach.
- All right. Okay.
- Oh, that's a small intestine.
That's the wrong thing!
(bones cracking)
Okay. I got his heart out.
Where's the heart? I see
lungs. I see a heart.
All right. The heart is in.
I'm going in for the stomach.
(bones cracking)
Okay. I got,
I got whatever it is out.
I got his stomach out.
That's the intestine. That's the ribs.
- You can do it.
- That looks like a stomach.
That kind of looks like a stomach.
I'm coming in with the stomach.
This should be his last
thing. Oh no, I dropped it.
(game chimes)
- Oh, we did it!
B, good job!
- What!
- That one was legit tough.
(Bianca yells)
- The controls.
- You did a great job
stabilizing him, though.
- You did awesome.
You're like a super spy.
- That was-
Super spy surgeon, like in
vents and stuff like that.
Ripping off people's limbs.
- B, I think we have
officially made ourselves
the Surgeon Simulator 2 champions.
- I think we did good. I think
we did it, we did very good.
- Honestly, it's just as chaotic
as the true operating room would be.
- Yes. Trying to find
limbs, cakes, hot dogs.
Going through vents, ripping off limbs.
- Bianca and I actually
played another game before
of would you rather, doctor,
nurse playing would you rather,
that's a good watch, click
here to check it out.
And as always, stay happy and healthy.
(upbeat electronic music)